citizens of the reject Nation welcome
and this is going to be a very different
video from me before we get into it
please do the YouTube things like
subscribe hit that notification Bell
comments because after I say the things
I'm about to say a lot of you might
leave so I'm saying it up front because
this is going to be a different kind of
video that might anger a decent amount
of you but I've been angry for a while
now and I've had this conversation with
a lot of people and I thought it was
time to have this conversation here with
you this is the reason for koi's Comic
Corner these are the kind of things I
want to start turning this into and if
this does well and if you like it please
do let me know leave a comment below
about this type of video basically I'm
going to be talking about my experience
with a certain thing in comic books that
I think is messy and I hope that you are
with me and if you disagree at least be
patient and at least uh try to see where
I'm coming from because it is spicy I
think not rebooting the Snyder cut is
the best thing for Batman and Superman
and on top of that I think we need the
Batman and Superman that we're about to
get with the DCU more than ever because
of the Snyder cut
so right at the top I just need to
address the fact that there are people
that think that Superman should be
murderous should wear a black suit all
the time should be the version of him
that snaps someone's neck and I
understand that between the Zack Snyder
films and the animated series and all of
these things that is a version of the
character that they see as the true
version of the character I should also
say at the top that I think Zack Snyder
and Deborah Snyder are absolutely
fantastic I think they are genius
creators I think she is one a Powerhouse
producer he is a Powerhouse producer
director Creator but I think what that
little Universe has spawned is a very
very tricky situation while liking the
Snyders I've had conversations with the
Snyder so I know that I like them as
people and know that I enjoy these
Snyder films but I will completely own
that I think of the Snyder films as an
else world I think of the Snyder
Superman and Batman as something that
would be a take on the character that
wouldn't be Canon and that's gonna be
what this is that's this conversation
Superman was invented in 1938. Superman
was invented by two scrawny Jewish guys
as a means to cope with the depression
that was going on leading up to World
War II being picked on and they made a
symbol of Hope and this symbol of Hope
has become a symbol of aggression and
violence that a lot of people are
arguing like yeah but it's growth it's
an ark it's a trajectory you need the
trajectory to start with the essence of
the character and then have something
change the dark character takes work
because they're a dichotomy the reason
that Craven's the last Hunt is
interesting is because it's like whoa
what's happening to Spider-Man Back in
Black likewise the reason that Batman is
interesting is because he is very
different to Superman and their dynamic
duo hood is because they are different
if Superman is as dark as Batman then
he's no longer about altruism and hope
he becomes a cautionary tale now I
mentioned 1938 I mentioned these two
skinny Jewish guys making a figure for
hope I also need to acknowledge the fact
that them being Jewish is so essential
to the character in that we've now made
him a Christ figure which is the most
white American thing to do when he
literally was delivered a la Bread
Basket like Moses a very Jewish
iconography so this is a story of an
alien an immigrant a person that is
trying to be the best possible version
that has become this this angry God he's
become this Old Testament God for
multiple movies so much so they put him
in a black suit when we hadn't really
had the positive one yet if in the first
film he snapped someone's neck by the
time he gets to the black suit well I
don't see much of a difference if you
get to this character that is supposed
to represent what we can become and what
we can become is someone that doesn't
think to save civilians as he's flying
through buildings who has a higher body
count than most the villains we've seen
in comic book movies then that's not
something to Aspire towards the reason
Superman is in a bright suit with
external underwear is to make us think
that man that's comfort in believing in
yourself man that is the ultimate in
this golly GE attitude of just hope and
belief and dreams and I think a huge
problem with the the world that is has
been spawned by this Superman and again
I have a lot of love for Zack Snyder and
I have a lot of love for Deborah Snyder
and I have a lot of love for DC fans
that haven't become this aggressive
angry cult that is getting DC in issues
the world of DC the the shape of Warner
Brothers is lesser for this very very
vocal vitrollic group of people that
threaten that troll that become issues
to the properties at large that cause
box office issues but because now the
suits that aren't comic fans don't know
how to steer this ship they tried to
make the Snyder cut it had to be
released in the way it was because of a
lot of other situations but if you even
if you look at the movies that were
working if you look at bvs it had a 69
drop off from week one to two yes it
made 830 million dollars worldwide but
the drop off when people heard about it
was substantial because a lot of people
like me didn't see that as their
Superman and now don't have a place to
talk about it every time I mentioned
Superman all I get is this well that's a
really interesting novel idea of the
character oh well Superman's not this
anymore or my favorite oh the world we
live in is dark and gritty and Superman
should reflect that Superman as I said
at the top reflects what we're trying to
get out of if Superman reflects the
world it's not Superman Superman is our
aspirational character while Batman is
our cautionary tale they invented
Superman as something to achieve to
escape how bad the world was if we make
him dark and gritty we're looking in at
ourselves and going like I guess that's
fine I guess that's enough we'll just
stay here we need a Superman like the
one they look to be adapting All-Star
Superman has the opening issue literally
have Lex Luthor trick Superman into
killing himself via the sun doesn't need
Krypton doesn't need doomsday doesn't
need things it shows the genius of Lex
Luthor which is a human that can take
out a God it shows Superman doing
anything he can to save everyone even
realizing man the sun itself is the
thing that that gives me my power how
ironic it might be thing it kills me but
accepting that he helped save people so
that was worth it we need the literal
son he's a Sun God we look to the Sun
for hope I am so sick of people not
realizing that this character represents
the thing on his chest I am so sick of
very very angry people going I want my
hero to be angry like me I think there's
a point in every young man's life and
I'd say a lot of young women's life but
I've never been a young woman where they
go like I don't get Superman because
he's too golly gee he's too powerful
he's too strong he has no weaknesses I
get all that I used to feel that way but
I think there's a point when you realize
oh he's a figurehead to represent what
we can be he shouldn't be realistic he
shouldn't be something that we can
actually aspire to if you achieve your
goals they're no longer goals if you've
ever wanted something really bad when
you got it it kind of felt like well
that wasn't what I wanted it's because
dopamine is from wanting a thing not
actually always achieving the thing
Superman should be that he should be the
Line in the Sand that moves you should
always try to be better even Superman
always tries to be better so I am so
sick of people wanting this gritty
Superman I am so sick of Snyder fans
that aren't fans that are cultists that
have manipulated his vision into their
vision of being angry trolling and
beings and threatening and and harming
mentally emotionally and sometimes
physically others because they
misinterpret a character that was
written before their parents were born
in most cases to not be this version so
while I love the Snyder films I think
they have harmed the pop culture
Zeitgeist and that has harmed the world
we look to Art to be a commentary on our
time if we keep making our commentary in
our time so shitty so angry so vitrolic
we're because we'll keep living that way
when the world is Jaded and the world
needs Superman that's when Superman is
there is the purpose of Superman to be
the antithesis to our jadedness to our
Gloom to our struggle in fact the reason
I think the authorities coming in is
it's kind of that story I think the
authority is a very Snyder's take on
Batman and Superman version but it's
intentionally a commentary I honestly
think it is a genius move of James Gunn
to bring in the authority because he's
the Snyder take on this universe it's
going to appease them but it's going to
be a very alarming moment when a certain
amount of twists happen and when people
realize that homelander is Donald Trump
it's going to be a moment and people are
going to be very upset but I honestly
think the authority is the same
commentary on this vengeful superhero
World in 1999 as the Snyder world is
today and I think it's an important
story to tell and honestly I think
that's what the authority is going to be
and I think it's going to be very
interesting when Amanda Waller ends up
dealing with the authority and The
Suicide Squad and the authority are
different commentaries on cautionary
tales about people with powers and all
of that ties into the darkness of the
world we've been living with DC and
that's why it needs to be brighter
that's why we need the Green Lantern and
Brightest Day and darkest night we've
been living in a [__] dark night I
think Zack Snyder just didn't like weebs
we barely saw any Clark Clark was not in
those movies and when he was the lowest
Lane relationship was really stiff and
sterile and this is Amy Adams and Henry
Cavill two of the most talented actors
is not like they can't do that job but
they didn't make Clark a person because
he never got to be just a a Shucks kind
of guy and that's that's Clark because
he is so innocent and Earnest we never
saw that and I think the politeness of
Clark Kent along with his earnesty is
also a thing that drives a lot of people
that are going through a tempestuous
time and saying there's a beautiful
openness and welcomingness and and just
all wide-eyed Ness of Clark we don't get
to have if that Superman is vengeful the
reason it was so impactful when Clark
Kent and Superman got killed was because
he was this unattainable thing and to
kill Superman so early into his run and
to make him so dark kind of eliminates
the point and on top of that they kill
Jimmy Olsen Jimmy Olsen is the humanity
that is one of the things that Superman
looks to is like man I love these people
so much and Jimmy represents that they
killed that which in turn kills humanity
and earnesty and hope it's a very
literal metaphor just as the the Perry
white metaphor when Perry white is is
talking to to Clark in the in the Daily
Planet I think he says something like oh
we can't run this story it's not 1938.
that's Zack Snyder saying we can't make
a Superman that they did in 1938 that's
the character and I will be the first
one to say that archetypal characters
are important because of the lens you
see them through that they're a mirror
for you but just like Spider-Man
wouldn't work if he didn't have
responsibility Superman doesn't work if
he doesn't have hope so we need a
Superman that reflects the world we want
to be for the sake of the world again I
don't think we've ever been darker
between the Internet connecting us in
ways that we weren't ready for between
people having this false sense of
entitlement with fandom with their own
lives with perspectives on politics with
politics themselves the tribalism all
the things we've reached all of that is
just a one one hundredth of why we need
Superman and at the end of the day I do
think that's why Henry Cavill wasn't
able to come back I don't think it was
age as much as as that was the thing
that was publicly stated I think that
that was a factor obviously uh they want
to do you know a journey with Lois and
and you know Jimmy and all those things
and I understand that they said they're
keeping uh Aquaman and Flash for now I
don't know how true that is I wouldn't
say hey these four movies that are
coming out aren't essential they're
obviously going to need to keep
appearances that I'm not saying it is
true it isn't true I don't know I'm not
a DC but I am saying that the the reason
Henry Cavill the best Superman of my
lifetime I love Henry Cavill the reason
Henry Cavill might not have been able to
keep going with Superman even if it
wasn't for the age thing is the
association with this when you look at
Henry Cavill you don't see the Superman
that they wrote in 1938 you don't see
the Superman that's in All-Star Superman
they're adapting you don't see the
Superman from For All Seasons or the one
that is beautifully saving that girl in
all black because she might kill herself
one of the prettiest and most impactful
and sad Bittersweet pretty comic pages
of all time because he's also in Black I
know he's not all the time it's just the
image I have in my head if you have a
character that's that's close to killing
themselves and another character that's
angry and vengeful it's not The Duality
it's not the dichotomy it's not the
thing that Superman is those pages don't
work unfortunately with Henry Cavill and
I would have loved to have seen him come
back and get to play the Superman he
wanted he knew what Superman was he
talked about wanting to play that
Superman he got to for 30 seconds Black
Adam but I do think there was a lot of
stuff tied to it and I do think that
rebooting the Snyder cut is is not an
option I think that restarting the DC
Universe is the move and that's just
Superman Batman wise we get a Batman
that shot people and I I get that Batman
in the comics has used guns yeah
Spider-Man's uh you know accidentally
killed people and the X-Men have a
vengeful eras to where they like wanted
to take out Humanity but that makes them
the Brotherhood of evil mutants if you
adapt the X-Men and they want to kill
Humanity that's not the X-Men it's the
brother who moves just because in the
comic books doesn't mean it's accurate
different writers have different takes
again archetypal character but you've
got to look at the the sum of all the
parts and Batman is a character who's in
his own way superstitious who has rules
if Batman doesn't have rules he's the
joke that's the point of the Joker the
reason Batman and Joker exists is to
show the difference in those characters
if Batman has no rules and will use a
gun how is he different than the
two-faced side of Harvey Dent the reason
Harvey Dent is so interesting is because
he represents the order of Batman as
well as the chaos of the Joker and
Batman seeing himself in that the White
Knight of the Dark Knight is Harvey Dent
you need Batman to have rules and his
parents being killed by a gun is why he
literally and there's there's very
iconic frames where he snaps a gun in
half and says this is the weapon of
cowards so the fact that we had a Batman
that used guns on his car the fact that
we had a Batman that that frankly
murdered defeats the purpose of Batman
Batman should be a cautionary tale yes
he should be someone very close to the
edge he should be someone
psychologically abused and broken he
should be someone that is taking out his
pain on the mentally ill Batman is not
something to necessarily aspire to be
he's cool yeah Batman's cool but you
need to also be like that's not good
that's why Pat and Batman is so great he
would not want to be Robert Pattinson
losing his mind just punching that
person until he's broken the reason that
the Batman patents and worked so well is
that the symbol of hope he represents
the end him realizing that I am
Vengeance can be co-opted by the weak
that I am vengeance is not the answer
the reason he needs to be a Spirit of
Hope much like Superman in fact the Arc
of Robert Pattinson's Batman is the arc
we as a society need to take with
Superman vengeance
is a cautionary tale if you live angry
and you live vengeful you're not living
we had a vengeful violent Batman that
that only got worse and more violent we
had the Thomas Wayne Batman from an else
world we had this character that did not
work in a world where we need hope and
again like I said with Superman we need
hope now more than ever so we need to
look at a new Batman which is going to
be Batman with his family when we look
at this Batman as father of Damian Wayne
the darkness of Damian Wayne makes Bruce
Wayne lighter I think there's a very
specific reason they're bringing in
Damian Wayne Damien Wayne is not as
beloved a character as Dick Grayson he's
not as beloved as Tim but he is a
character that changes Bruce and I think
it's going to be very interesting adding
a maternal element I think that Batman
has always had a paternal element with
his Wards and with his robins and those
certain things that give you that
beautiful dichotomy between his
upbringing when he was raised he didn't
have a family so all he wanted was a
family if you look at the dichotomy
between the Joker who is is the thing he
he can't be because of chaos or like I
said Harvey dents or how Mr Freeze is
his opposite because his love for Nora
mirrors Bruce's love for Gotham or the
guilt of Nora mirroring his guilt of his
family all of Batman's best Rogues are
mirrors of Batman that's why he's a
psychological character that's why he
works in so many different ways the
reason all these characters sing
Catwoman being a thief and Batman loving
her is him feeling the guilt of that the
reason all this works is Batman is all
of us but we should aspire to be
Superman and I love the idea of Batman
being all of us and going I never had a
family I have a son of Batman going like
look at this little [__] he's killing
people and harming others I gotta fix
that but he's my son so I can't do what
I usually do with criminals that's going
to be a great story and because of when
it takes place in his life him being
older that allows for Dick Grayson to
argue Nightwing that allows for
potential Red Hood greatness that allows
for all of these stories deeper into the
Mythos and because we haven't had a
Batman with a family yet this is a great
way to separate Robert Pattinson's you
can have your darking Brewing Batman
that I love the David Fincher Batman
while also having a fun a little bit
lighter perhaps even as light as like
you know bat shark repellent probably
not but you you could have a lighter
Batman in the family Batman and that's
because of Damien Wayne I'm not saying
he's slapstick I'm not saying it's going
to be brightly colored tights it might
be Neil Adams blue that'd be cool I'd
like to see you around this blue but I
do think Damian Wayne establishes a tone
I think that was a very smart
announcement I think putting Batman
older than Superman allows for a very
interesting story of Batman being a more
seasoned veteran while maybe Superman's
on year three he's not it's not her
origin every keeps saying the Superman
origin but I do think having Superman
younger than Batman allows for a
different kind of conversation about
Batman's fear and apprehension at first
of Superman and how a lighter Superman
is gonna be much better suited to the
broad Justice League Strokes a lighter
Superman is much better suited to
encounter a Green Lantern if the Green
Lantern landed in Gotham that penguin
Colin Farrell's running around in that
would ruin the entire world that that
world they built would be done so I
think this Batman is the best possible
thing to fit in the Justice League and
expand that shared Universe out I think
this Superman is the best possible thing
for our shared Universe because we need
to believe in things again so if this
video pissed you off I'm sorry and I
don't want you to take that out on me or
anyone else I think Superman will be
something that hopefully you can find to
not see as cheesy for being bright that
you cannot see as wow he's just got all
these Powers that's boring because the
point is Hope and aspiration and to
believe in something greater than
ourselves he's supposed to be better
than us we're supposed to want to be him
and he's supposed to want to be us
Superman should not reflect our world
our world should try to reflect Superman
Batman should not be something we want
to be we should want to help Batman I
really really think these new takes are
going to be fantastic and I really
really hope that if you've been dealing
with some of the more Angry DC fans it
hasn't changed your love for DC Comics I
love DC Comics I love these characters I
talk about Marvel a lot because I've
never felt comfortable dealing with some
of the more negative DC fans and they've
only gotten bigger more empowered and
and stronger in their mind it's not
started with me not having as much to
say because there weren't as many
adaptations of DC that the adaptations
came out and just I got driven out of
town and I'm not going to do that
anymore I'm not going to be weak I'm not
going to be a subservient to trolls I'm
not going to let the enemy win so don't
make yourself an enemy of comic books
don't make yourself an enemy of DC
change is important and these characters
are important to a lot of people stop
being a dick all right much love you
lovelies citizens of reject Nation uh if
you like this type of video let me know
[Music]